alors quoi de beau
alors quoi de beau ce week-end c'est la
fin des vacances dans les Yvelines
j'espère que vous avez bien profité moi
en tout cas là j'étais au max du profit
j'espère que j'ai profité pour ceux qui
pouvaient pas profiter
lundi 8 mai c'est férié petit week-end
prolongé on pourra profiter pour ceux
qui peuvent profiter moi en tout cas je
ne peux plus profiter samedi il pleut
dans les Yvelines dimanche il pleut pas
mais lundi il replay une belle rentrée
quoi aujourd'hui pour ce micro-trottoir
on va parler de la journée
internationale du mot de passe mais
avant ça une petite page de jeu concours
n'hésitez pas à participer
avec un stylo du 70
j'avais des fuites
tu verras tu iras ta meilleure vie des
stylos de couleurs différentes
pour écrire une histoire passionnante
c'est super stylo écrivent à l'encre
bleue différents coloris sont
disponibles bleu air bleu vert et blanc
et blanc vert et blanc pour participer
identifier un comparse dans les comes de
commentaires seront tirés au sort tentez
votre chance smiley good luck les
gagnants seront contactés sur Instagram
le réseau social qui appartient à Mark
Zuckerberg en cas de casse du présent
veuillez vous référer au mail vraiment à
du mail.com en fait samedi c'est la
journée mondiale du mot de passe est-ce
que vous avez des mots de passe à nous
partager là des conseils de mot de passe
c'est-à-dire
de changer assez régulièrement
régulièrement tout à fait c'est la
première fois que je sais déjà une
journée du mot de passe assez nouveau
la journée mondiale du mot de passe
c'est que ça doit être une journée où on
distribue plus de serrure que de clés
comme les applications quand j'ai besoin
de savoir je demande à un jeune je sais
que ils connaissent ils vont me dire ils
vont m'expliquer après là c'est bon
est-ce que vous avez des techniques moi
j'utilise un seul mode passe depuis plus
de 15 ans et le prénom de ma mère et le
prénom de mon père en majuscule avec les
dates de leur naissance respective on
peut avoir le nom de votre père le nom
de votre nom avec nous ça ouvre quoi ça
finalement changer ça me dit alors pour
la journée mondiale du mot de passe
c'est ça c'est exactement ça
effectivement nous avons prévu
effectivement un rassemblement secret
dont le lieu sera
la nature du Dieu sera délivrée
sur les réseaux sociaux le plus
tardivement possible là je mets le flou
je vous en supplie
nous rendons que rassemblement de la
secte du mot de passe durant laquelle
effectivement nous sacrifierons des mots
de passe on en a après de six mois
attention c'est pas évident comment on
rejoint si imaginons j'ai un beau mot de
passe à cramer
il faut absolument que ce soit le vôtre
que vous souhaitiez effectivement
délivrer ça c'est très important le
consentement c'est très important en
délivrant effectivement vos coordonnées
votre groupe Rhésus et votre pointure
gauche avec en recommandé mais sans
accusé de réception surtout puisque nous
ne accusons absolument personne
ok en fait on m'a conseillé d'utiliser
les longues phrases sans espace mais
avec des points c'est pas du tout pas
mal mais j'ai déjà mes idées moi
vous le dites et moi je bip au montage
comment ah oui vous pouvez le dire
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]